let's talk about what's probably the
best chance we'll ever get to save the
planet and ourselves this pandemic has
given us a kind of glimpse on just how
nature can mess with us if we mess with
nature
and we know it's a mess but for a while
there nobody was driving or flying
factories shut down our carbon footprint
shrank a few sizes but now now the
global economy is chucking back to life
and all those people pushing for a
sustainable future well they're warning
you can't go back to business as usual
this pandemic is a wake-up call so how
did the pandemic affect the environment
and is it possible to bring back the
economy without killing the planet
[Music]
with kovin 19 the earth basically caught
a break and maybe we have to for
starters the global shutdown did a lot
of environmental good people noticed
suddenly the air we breathe is cleaner
than it has been for decades air
pollution has been radically cut
emissions have plummeted and suddenly
everybody's talking about nature it
happened fast almost overnight cities
like Beijing and New Delhi which usually
choke on smog were able to enjoy baby
blue skies bees could smell flowers and
find food more easily because of less
car fumes deserted streets also meant
some wild animals made a bit of a
comeback though the return of swans and
dolphins to Venice
well that was fake but still we have
really an opportunity now and it would
be a shame to miss it and to just go
back to this very polluted high climate
risk world that we had before
over the last decade co2 emissions have
been rising around one percent every
year when things like cars planes and
factories but all of that activity
ground to a halt during the pandemic an
experts think that by early April global
co2 emissions have decreased by around
17 percent that decrease comes largely
from Road Transport the lockdown is a
brutal way to do it but you can see the
size of the effect but it's not all been
rosy
billions of us have been told to wear
gloves and masks and wear more
protective gear and it's all piling up
on the mountains of garbage we're
already dealing with
[Music]
that were protected because of tourism
and the money that came with it suddenly
became targets for poachers and the
world lost more rainforests in March it
was more than twice the monthly average
while this pandemic has been going on
we've had no end of big corporations
making the most of it and taking out
huge chunks of forest not least in
Amazonia and Indonesia and so forth the
fundamental reason for this pandemic
actually happening was because of a
zoonotic disease it's spread from
animals to humans the more you do that
the more opportunity there is for
diseases like cope of nineteen to break
out and bring the world the human world
to a standstill that standstill is now
starting to look more like a slow
shuffle lockdowns are lifting economies
are powering back up again and emissions
are returning to pre-pandemic levels
which is worrying because even before
this crisis we had ambitious climate
goals and we're behind right now the
rise in global temperature is around one
degree Celsius above pre-industrial
levels and we're already feeling it
there have been more wildfires longer
droughts the storms are crazy ice caps
are melting sea levels are rising but
we're on track to hit a one and a half
degree rise by 2030 and soar past that
if emissions keep going up now even half
a degree may not sound like much but
it's a world of difference at a 1 and a
half degree rise the arctic ocean would
be ice-free at least once every 100
years at 2 degrees that's once every 10
at one and a half degrees sea levels
would be 10 centimeters lowered by the
end of the century then they'd be with a
2 degree hike coral reefs well they're
in bad shape regardless to stop that
happening we need to get carbon levels
down a growing number of countries and
companies are signing up to the goal of
zero carbon by 2050 that means cutting
emissions but also finding ways to
remove carbon from the atmosphere until
the net gain
zero and to do it in 30 years we put out
lovely nice sustainable development
goals at the international level but in
normal life sustainability is really
difficult ask but these aren't normal
times which is why this is seen as an
opportunity what if we don't fully go
back to our old ways what if as people
in the climate change business are
saying we rethink how we recover from
this economic meltdown cities like Milan
Athens in London already have plans to
reallocate street space from cars to
cycling and walking president macro in
France is promising billions of dollars
to the French car industry if they focus
on producing clean green electric
vehicles and the government planned to
rescue air france that is contingent on
the carrier scrapping some domestic
flights so encouraging the use of people
traveling by train of course for every
macro phone you have a Boston area or
Trump as in politicians resistant to
green policies which for climate
scientists is a problem because what
they all say over and over is that to
stop climate change we have to think big
now what we haven't seen yet is really
demonstration that governments have
understood the scale of the action I
mean it's not about building a few cycle
pass here and there most fundamental
things that needs to be changed is how
we measure the economy because I think
that sort of sits at a rooted problem as
Hart's talking about gross domestic
product which is the total value of the
goods and services produced by a country
usually measured over a year the more
GDP grows the healthier that economy is
seen to be and that model has lifted
hundreds of millions of people out of
poverty but the cost to the planet isn't
factored into GDP things like pollution
climate change and the planet's
resources it's why economists say that
model isn't sustainable
so GDP has been a great tool for the
last 17 years in many ways it's reaching
the end of its usefulness we have an
economic system that kind of drives us
into some seeming [ __ ] producing lines
that in many ways is what many
governments want us to get back to but a
lot of people say we don't have to go
there climate activists and economists
are pointing to trillions of dollars on
the table right now the governments of
earmark to revive economies it's a huge
amount of emergency cash Romans really
have the opportunities now to take a
hard look at their stimulus package and
to make sure that this is as green as
possible
if those trillions of dollars are
invested in restoring the fossil fuel
economy it will lock in basically the
worst effects of climate change but if
those trillions real instead invested in
and move to a zero carbon economy they
could open up enormous investment
opportunities and bring back millions
into gainful employment and preserve
livable to the bargain the point they're
making is some of that money being used
to recover from the pandemic could be
used to avoid an even bigger catastrophe
if we think this is bad we ain't seen
nothing yet because if the climate
crisis really kicks in huge swathe of
coastline will be uninhabitable hundreds
of millions of people will be affected
they could be climate refugees in in New
York State that could be climate
refugees in the home counties of England
job losses disease social disorder you
name it it's kovat times 10 obviously
nobody wants that to happen and right
now there's money and opportunity to
make sure it doesn't
on a scale none of us have ever seen so
you kind of have to wonder whether this
is
last best chance to get it right there's
plenty going on in the world so if
there's a story in the news that's
complicated and you want us to explain
it let us know get in touch with us on
Twitter or Facebook and make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel so you
don't miss our next episode I'll see you
next week
you
[Music]